[Music]
the surgeon has come
[Applause]
she was taken forever since no it was an
accident god will look after her now
a sea creature has been spotted
there's something out there that's what
i'm here to find out
i've done some research into a mythical
beast not mythical real
the serpent is an invention
a symptom of the times we live in so
you're against progress
i'd rather believe in a creature people
have actually seen than an invisible god
is that blasphemy
we won't get my husband to judge you no
matter how hard you try
everyone's a little on edge at the
moment lock your door say your prayers
you're trying to understand trying to
find the truth we must all follow our
passions i couldn't agree more
i'm scared it's in us
we put it here robot
i need to forget about essex i want you
to come back
sounds like you're in love with her
everyone else is
i scared them you didn't start all this
we can't control our inner thoughts but
they can influence us
it was woman that was tempted by the
serpent it was woman that ate the fruit
you let them accuse me you said nothing
i'm their pastor so you can't be my
friend and a man of god i can't think
clearly when i'm around you i won't be
blamed for your weakness love is not a
weakness
i think the essex serpent has sunk its
claws into you too
[Music]
every one of us lives with doubt and
fear
and now is the time for us to come
together don't be scared it's one of the
most lost
[Applause]
[Music]
that the source of light is closest
[Music]
[Music]
you